breaking overnight hours after passing a
major infrastructure bill with
bipartisan support the senate took
another big step to push through
president biden's agenda it narrowly
approved a three and a half trillion
dollar blueprint for family health and
environmental programs much of that
would be paid for with higher taxes on
wealthy americans and corporations chris
van cleave is on capitol hill for us
chris good morning to you what's next
tony good morning now they have to take
this framework and turn it into an
actual bill and what's inside that bill
is going to be crucial to passing not
only the budget act but also this
infrastructure bill they agreed on
yesterday if they manage to do that they
will deliver on many of president
biden's promises but the road ahead
could be rough and long
the yeas are 50
the nays are 49
and the concurrent resolution as amended
is agreed to
this morning the senate approved a 3.5
trillion dollar budget resolution
setting the framework for a massive
budget bill loaded with progressive
social programs including child and
senior care and money to combat climate
change the 50-49 party-line vote came
after an overnight vote-a-rama on a
lengthy series of non-binding amendments
this amendment is just plain anti-pickup
truck let's start there opposing my
amendment is a vote in support of
defunding the police some senators
expressed exasperation at the procedure
so let all of us a hundred people not
walk but sashay down there and vote for
this amendment but earlier tuesday
bipartisanship briefly reign
as the senate overwhelmingly passed a
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure bill
on this vote
the a's are 69. 19 gop senators joined
democrats in voting to rebuild the
nation's highways bridges public transit
and expand access to broadband after
years and years of infrastructure week
we're on the cusp of an infrastructure
decade
that i truly believe will transform
america
tennessee's bill hagerty voted no they
call the infrastructure bipartisan but i
think what it reveals is the strategy
deployed by the majority leader he
wanted to put the patina of
bipartisanship on this initial package
he wanted to create a series of of
actions real momentum toward this 3.5
trillion dollar spending spree that's
going to be a debt bomb for america the
infrastructure measure heads to the
house but speaker nancy pelosi won't
allow a vote until the senate passes
that 3.5 trillion dollar budget bill the
total vision is about not only building
physical infrastructure but building
human infrastructure
and now speaker pelosi plans to call the
house back from recess early they are
expected to be back here august 23rd
that's about a month early where they
will take up the house version of that
budget resolution and possibly voting
rights vlad all right chris van cleef
coming to us from the hill we appreciate
it thank you